how metal was that eddie munson moment
in the stranger things season four
finale and why was it the perfect choice
for the character keep watching as we
break it all down
stranger things fans have had a
painstakingly long wait for the final
feature-length episodes of season four
after volume 1 arrived on may 27th but
netflix has finally released the last
two chapters and they drastically
changed the future of the hit series
while the end of volume 1 revealed that
the terrifying villain becna is not only
henry creel but also one volume 2 mainly
revolves around the gang's attempt to
kill him by using max's bait after all
he's already had a taste of her pain and
he wants to finish the job this is
partly because vechna's master plan
involves ripping open four gates across
hawkins using four deaths as a way of
bridging the real world with the upside
down mistakes have never been higher and
there's been talk of a tragic death in
the series since before this season
started so it's a little nerve-wracking
when steve nancy and robin all lie and
wait for becknet at the creel house
while dustin and eddie keep the demo
bats distracted with an impromptu metal
concert at the trailer park
unfortunately the battle comes at high
price for eddie the leader of the
hellfire club has been a big focus this
season since the hawkins townsfolk think
he's responsible for the deaths of
chrissy fred and patrick it's all down
to the very real satanic panic that
gripped the united states in the 1980s
which led many to believe that dungeons
and dragons was part of some sinister
evil plot to corrupt young people
these murders are ritualistic sacrifices
although eddie spends most of his time
hiding and going on the run he armors up
to help steve nancy robin and dustin in
the upside down eddie's idea of
distracting the demo bats is a pretty
inspired one he grabs the upside down
version of his electric guitar and
climbs on top of the trailer to
absolutely shred metallica's master of
puppets as a siren song to draw the demo
bats away from the kreel house it's an
act that fits his character perfectly
since he's a metal head as well as the
dungeon master it's a pretty appropriate
song choice too since vechna is also a
master of the upside down the scene
allows eddie to let loose for a few
minutes after spending days hiding in
the woods by lover's leg he just gets
lost in the music knowing that it's
helping in the fight against vecna are
you ready for the most metal concert in
the history of the world eddie's
performance is another example of how
powerful music can be in the series
after all kate bush is running up that
hill is max's hopeful anthem to pull
herself out of the upside down in
episode four but eddie putting himself
on the line shows he's grown up a bit
unfortunately eddie and dustin's plan
works a little too well and they have to
deal with a huge swarm of demo bats that
assault the trailer eventually breaking
in through the vents the beasts are
small but they're vicious dustin climbs
through the gate back into the real
world but eddie severs the makeshift
sheetrobe so that he can't come back
through and get hurt obviously this
leaves eddie trapped in the upside down
it's a selfless act of heroism and it
proves that eddie isn't afraid to grow
up and take responsibility for his own
actions although at first it looks like
eddie might get away from the demo bats
on a bike one of them knocks it out from
underneath him and he's suddenly swarmed
by the monsters choosing to save dustin
while drawing the demo bats away from
his young sidekick in the creel house
proves that eddie has grown up since the
start of the season when he jokes about
being held back at high school and
refusing to conform with society
although dustin gets back through the
gate to find his friend he's too late
and in a heartbreaking goodbye eddie
passes the mantle of dungeon master onto
him noting that he didn't run away this
time fans have been worried about
eddie's fate for a while and this loss
definitely hurts considering how
charismatic joseph quinn was in the role
but at least it had meaning
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things season 4 coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one